c'est dans ce laboratoire que spoutnik v
devrait être fabriquée en très grande
quantité
depuis l'annnonce de sa découverte par
la russie le vaccin suscite à la fois
beaucoup d'espoir dans la lutte contre
le coronavirus mais aussi un certain
scepticisme
le précieux remède a été approuvé par le
ministère russe de la santé
avant la phase iii des essais cliniques
soit le stade le plus avancé ce qui
n'entame pas la confiance des dirigeants
du centre de fabrication
il est certain que la vaccination
provoque la formation d'anticorps
spécifiques notamment de protection
on peut ajouter que durant la période de
vaccination des bénévoles
le titre d'anticorps a été suffisant
c'est ici que se déroule l'étape finale
de la fabrication au cours de laquelle
le vaccin est inspecté dans le cadre du
contrôle qualité
si les unités de vaccin parce
l'inspection elles sont ensuite
étiquetés et préparer pour être emballée
jusqu'à 120 mille flacons par jour sont
ainsi préparés une cadence infernale qui
vise à atteindre le milliard de doses
précommandée à travers le monde selon
les autorités russes
une vingtaine de pays se seraient déjà
manifestés pour acquérir spoutnik v